Fox Business Alert, Nvidia rallying the
AI troops and the troops are falling in
line. The AI chip leader just posted on
its blog that industry heavyweights have
come together to form what's called the
Open Secure AI Alliance. This is an
artificial intelligence defense program.
The new coalition includes Adobe, Cisco,
CrowdStrike, Dell, IBM, Microsoft,
Palantir, Salesforce, SpaceX and many,
many more. The security alliance aims to
create and deploy open-source AI tools
that companies can use to defend against
cyber attacks. The Nvidia-backed
coalition specifically highlighted last
week's incident where OpenAI's agents
broke containment out of their sandbox,
went on a hacking spree and on their own
attacked an AI platform called Hugging
Face. The companies say this is a prime
example of why the framework will help
manage AI agent behavior more
effectively while simplifying testing,
tracking and improving oversight. What
do you guys think? Well, joining me now
in a Fox Business exclusive is a member
of this new [music] AI defense squad,
Palantir CEO Alex Karp. There are a
couple of things to attack here, to
tackle here, I should say. This and then
there was the open letter on Friday
about open-weight AI models and urging
the US government not to ban them. But
let's start with this. What was behind
your joining this alliance?
>> Well, I mean, the first of all, the the
there's a
there's a broader movement which really
kind of was kicked off a couple weeks
ago
when when
we partnered with Nvidia and then talked
about
um
how do you build sovereign AI, meaning
AI where we're in the enterprise space.
So, how do you build an AI stack so that
you not only get what you pay for, so
you're not token maxing, meaning just
paying for tokens that are waste of
time, but as importantly, that you're
not transferring the value of your
business to a frontier lab. So, one of
the big worries, one of the things
that's quite a lot caused a lot of pain
and consternation in American enterprise
is, hey, I'm paying for tokens and
you're getting the alpha of my business.
Because when when they look at your
data, when they look at your telemetry,
and there's a lot of contractual things
that can be taken advantage of, you're
basically transferring the value of your
business to them. Now, we have 20 years
experience, we were born in the
battlefield of building products where
the end client basically can advance and
bring the troops home, which is very
similar to how do you make sure you can
use your data and you use it in a way
where you keep the advantage of your
business?
>> The IP.
>> The IP. Uh what makes your business
valuable? Every single business in
America, and we're I'm on the front line
with businesses, some of the most
important in the world, and some of the
most important enterprises in the world,
both in America and in allied countries,
and they all have this Actually, they're
enraged. So, we we
we launched essentially a movement of,
you know, you need to own your compute,
you need to own your application layer.
Most people view that as an an ontology,
which is a fancy way of saying, how do
you make the value models valuable? And
then you need to be able to control
either closed models, frontier models,
or get open models and and help train
them yourself.
And the Palantir part of this, the the
alliance that was kind of forged was,
how do we do this? And the reason why
it's working so well is their demand for
this is almost endless.
Downstream from that alliance is each
one of these components we want to be
something that the end user, meaning the
enterprise, can actually purchase, own,
and not get abused by.
One important part of that is the
models. Now,
our clients
want to control models, meaning if
they're closed models, so from Infroptic
as an example, they want to make sure
that they can use that model in a way
that it's valuable, and that they can
make sure that the value of their
business is not being monetized
moved to them.
>> But Alex, you're saying keep things
open with the open weight letter, which
basically said that the US government,
and this is Treasury Secretary Scott
Bessent, who is considering
uh banning or at least ring-fencing some
of these because many of them come from
China. We're talking about the Kimmy and
you know, you've got Alibaba's Qwen.
This open letter says, "Let's
make sure that you guys don't They it
urged the government not to ban or
ring-fence them."
>> there's there's my The ring-fencing and
banning are very different thing. Look,
we have a template for what doesn't
work. It's called Europe.
What did Europe do?
>> Shut everybody else out.
>> Shut everyone else out. What does Europe
tech What does Europe's tech scene look
like? It's
We We Our business is booming in
America, and one of our brand
advantages, unfortunately, across the
world is Europe is like trying to find
ways to keep companies like Palantir
out.
You One of the big problems we have in
AI is it is actually dependent on its on
the models being orchestrated and
managed both for safety reasons and for
value reasons. That's an application
layer. We see on the front line in our
classified deployments where we're using
open weight models that we can get those
models to be as good or better than
frontier models.
>> Even the Chinese ones?
>> We We can get our models to be as good
or better than any model on the planet.
>> So So So just a minute. The What you
want in a stack is an American stack
that's American based on every single
part of that stack is the best part.
>> about chips?
>> Chips, ontology, chips
>> racks
>> Yeah, no, actually, it's it's like so
you have you have GPUs, and then you
have the models, and in between those
models are powered by an application
layer. Part of what's happened,
honestly, is that, you know, and these
Dario is an incredibly world-historic
figure,
>> Dario Amodei of Anthropic
>> You're you're selling a model that
actually only works at that level safely
if you
if you modulate it and use it on
>> one in enterprise. People want that
safety, Alex.
>> Yeah, so the application layer allows
for the safety, but also for creating
these things, using them so they're
actually valuable.
A way of not addressing that issue is to
say, "Oh, okay, we we can't have any
competition because the competition
might be dangerous." Now, of course, the
competition could be dangerous.
But, we have to you always have to be
very careful. We cannot go down the path
of I mean, I'm very pro-European. I've
watched Europe regulate itself out of
business. You end up with businesses
that no one believes are businesses
because they only exist behind the
firewall of regulation. That doesn't
mean we shouldn't watch all of these
models very carefully, both open and
closed. But, most importantly, what our
clients want, primarily US clients, is
they want to be able to control a model,
either closed model, or they want to be
able to control the weights so they keep
the alpha in an environment that's safe,
and they have this kind of vulgar, you
know, no application layer, no love
saying that they're all saying, and they
want to make sure that it's valuable on
the front line.
>> Was this
a way to shut out, or is it an attack on
Anthropic because they didn't sign on,
and you have complained that they very
much control a lot of what would be the
tokens that that's a
>> Well, I can tell you I can look, I can't
Look, this revolution has taken off, and
you can't put it back in the bag, and I
think we helped launch it if maybe even
the leaders and a lot of people are now
following on. I'm not anti-Anthropic or
anti any of the closed models. I am pro
my customers, and my customers are
angry. And well, my customers are angry
because they feel like they got token
maxed while transferring their alpha to
a frontier lab that, by the way,
believes their business is only valuable
because they're going to put it out of
business.
>> It's money. It costs a lot.
>> No, it's not just it costs a lot. That's
one problem. The bigger problem is you
are migrating the value of your business
to the person you're paying a lot of
money to.
Like, and so the the what what's making
businesses businesses are used to paying
too much and throttling it down.
Businesses don't like when they're
paying too much and then they find out
that somehow the actual insights of the
business
>> Yes.
>> are being modeled by a far third party
and sold to other people or they're
losing their business. And by the way,
this is not this is not just a fake
concern. This is happening all over. And
that, by the way, by the way, this is
very important for America. What slows
down AI adoption in this country is not
primarily our fear of a third-party
country we compete with. God knows I'm
on the front line of that as part of
Palantir. What slows down AI adoption in
this country is people are saying, "But
I can't use these products cuz I'm not
getting value, meaning I'm not using an
application layer, and I or I'm
transferring the value of my business to
someone else. Why would I do that?"
>> I get that, Alex, but you have
consistently said, "Either we win or
China wins." You You have said that
Those are your words, but let me just
say that by allowing open weight
platforms like the Chinese ones to not
be, again, ring-fenced or banned by the
US government,
>> I I just sorry.
>> Is that not a contradiction?
>> No. You First of all, I I
Looking at models very carefully in
regulating them, totally in favor of
whether they're American or or from
another country. I'm saying something
different.
>> Okay.
>> If you want to win,
you have to compete on the battlefield.
Let's just take a military example.
We're building some of the most
important AI systems in the world.
Complete stack is American
>> and of course.
>> Okay. Our job has to be to have the best
AI in the world. If you're going to
actually say we're going to restrict all
products to US commercial, but they're
not going to be restricted abroad, which
they're not, you're de facto setting up
a two-stage thing where no one can claim
we have the best products. It's just
complete insanity because we do have
Look, our pro- We are building our
platform in the US government on the
open weight side with Nvidia. It is We
can get the best performance in the
world with an totally American company
using American open way companies and
American GPUs. Now, we don't have to
hide behind some kind of fake thing.
When by the way, this only augurs to a
company which won't participate because
in many cases by the way, you just have
to ask yourself a different question. I
we keep saying if you don't have cyber
and AI, it's it's going to lead to
closed models migrating your IP and we
keep giving specific things. There's no
response.
>> Is this the free market version that
you're calling for when it comes to AI
models?
>> Uh what I'm calling for is a free market
with oversight.
I'm not saying there shouldn't be any
oversight. In fact, I'm very pro
oversight on open and closed models. But
what I am saying is you have to be very
very careful. We know what Europe did.
We know what their texting looks like.
We have to be very careful not to
replicate that. That's not a way to be
like if you want to be pro actually the
French have a saying, if you care deeply
you're particularly exacting. And so we
should be very exacting. But exacting
and banning are very different things.
And then by the way, it won't work
anyway.
>> Sam Altman recently came out and said
that we have achieved singularity with
AI which means that it's beyond human
control.
Do you agree? I mean, is AI achieved any
fear of that at all? Elon Musk is
talking about it too.
>> Well, my version of it is and again,
this is where it's like we have to run
effectively. Meaning the enterprise
needs to be sovereign and you run
effectively because we do have
competition. That competition primarily
comes from China and other countries.
And so like there are all these dangers.
One of the one of the problems in the AI
messaging from Silicon Valley is it's
always presented as there's no danger.
Yeah, there are dangers. Just like if
you're built if you're working with
natural if you're working with the
uranium, there's a danger. The
processing and who controls it is very
important meaning how do you
>> regulated by the government. So Scott
Bessent wants to maybe regulate this and
do you agree with that?
>> I I we are going to end up having to
regulate AI. There's no doubt, but the
question is who regulates it? Do they
understand what they're doing? And is it
regulated in a way where we win? And so
like again, do you there's a like you
have hard regulation, which is Europe,
that clearly doesn't work. Then you have
no regulation, obviously I'm not in
favor of that, but then there's a
question of how do you do it? Under what
conditions? Does the person understand
what they're doing? These are very
complicated issues, and there's only one
country in the world that could get it
right or really get it wrong, and that's
us.
But because it could go either way
doesn't mean we shouldn't plow forward
and try to get this to work.
>> Well, uh a lot of people in Silicon
Valley, I'm not saying you, but they
fight regulation or they hold it up over
and over again.
>> Silicon Valley since inception. I fought
Silicon Valley cuz we're on the [music]
battlefield, because we believe
that I still fight like why would
Silicon Valley get to weigh in on what
the Department of War does? Like I think
that should be decided by the Department
of War. So, like by the way, I'm in
favor of regulating these things,
limiting them in the US surveillance
context, whatever you may have heard.
Like so, but [music] in the department
but like we've set Palantir has never By
the way, I personally am always
skeptical of like, you know, Republicans
think the free market will solve
everything, and Democrats think it or
left think it won't solve anything. The
truth is the middle position where you
need [music] smart and accurate and
exact regulation on these issues, just
like a tax policy.
>> [music]
>> I'm not in favor of having no tax. I'm
not In fact, I'm in favor of rich people
paying potentially more, but you can't
do it in a way that just punishes rich
people and doesn't help poor people,
like the wealth tax.
>> That doesn't help, exactly. Alex Karp,
good to have you. Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
>> Stay right there.
He always tries to get up and run off
the set. Is it that bad?
>> [laughter]
>> You always say that. I Thanks, Alex.
Coming up